would you ever do anything with a trans
porn star no
even if it was like [__] your wife
with a trans porn star
I don't feel like I want to turn our sex
life into a culture War thing you know
probably just
I'm not trying to like prove my wokeness
or anything and I [__] with a lot of
trans uh women and stuff like have had a
lot of them on the podcast I had Emma
Rose on the podcast I think I saw a
little bit of the uh you guys did like a
um a panel right it was like yeah yeah
yeah and I got to meet a lot of really
cool trans people in that situation and
everything but my whole thing is like
I'm not really trying to do anything on
camera for money that I wouldn't want
really in my private life as well yeah
so like I don't you know and even like
I'll like I'm not personally really like
Mega attracted to a BBW that's like 400
pounds right would I maybe do it on
camera like maybe yeah like that doesn't
would you pop a blue shoe
I might have to pop something I don't
know yeah my papa energy drink my pop is
C4
let's not give them any free [__]
publicity there all right that's why I
have their logo turned away from them
this guy's over here got the Celsius on
the floor
man we're over here drinking [__]
Energy Drinks like a couple of real
white guys like a couple of real Arizona
and New Hampshire white boys right
oh [__] now you know the one thing I
would say is like
I I've you know I have for whatever
reason I think people think we're like a
lot like we're cool like I think me and
you are cool I think we're friends you
know like but
I have so many people in my life that
came to me like I'm like your
representative and they're like yo son
what's up with your boy and I'm like at
the end of the day
this guy is a professional porn star
who's [__] however many hundreds of
women since he's been in his
relationship to me
it's not that big of a deal right
that she gets one yeah I mean it is
weird because it's like yeah I have
[__] all these chicks with her and
nobody really like ever made a big deal
about it like you know and it's a double
standard thing and it's also kind of
because we're like we're in hip-hop
culture and it I think that's where it
kind of like people are like yo like
bruh like yeah and I expected like
hip-hop to have strong opinions about it
but I didn't really expect there to be
like 20 bar stool articles and you know
to have like Andrew Tate Logan Paul all
these people like discussing it in depth
on their podcast and [__] you know I
didn't expect to have everyone in the
whole world having conversations about
it which that
surprised me there was I I want to say I
saw an old interview clip it might have
been when you were on flagrant where you
at pretty much I could be no you're
right yeah I shut the door on it you
pretty much shut the door hard on like
what changed which is weird because
maybe a year before that I remember I
went on academics's podcast and he asked
if I would ever do a threesome with
another dude and my girl and I basically
like left the door open for it and was
just kind of like you know yeah I would
be open to it like I would be interested
in it I didn't say that I was gonna do
it but I said I'd be open to the idea
and I remember even at that time just me
suggesting that I would maybe be down
for it was so viral and such a big thing
and academics freaked out and could not
believe that I was acknowledging it and
even on Vlad there was a clip I saw like
because I I talk on interviews so much
that I forget what I say and but I'm
glad I said the same thing I said like
I would consider it you know and so yeah
like the clipping went viral though was
me saying that I definitely wouldn't do
it which is pretty funny but uh yeah I
mean what changed is basically just me
getting a little bit more open-minded as
time went by and like you know me and
her talked about like swinging off
camera and like hooking up with like a
different couple together or something
like that take a Friday night go out on
the town get a hotel room something like
that maybe but then we were like well if
we're ever gonna do that like we
probably should film it and if we're
gonna we should make some money yeah you
should probably like make your first
scene with another guy like a big
blowout thing
pause